[S01] 呃，想象一下世界上最安全最高科技的数据中心
[S01] 你脑海里浮现的威胁可能就是黑客帝国里面那种疯狂的代码
[S01] 或者是某种极其复杂的恶意软件，对吧？
[S02] 嗯，大多数人其实都会往网络攻击那个方向想。
[S01] 但是如果我告诉你，
[S01] 现实中发生过这样一件事，
[S01] 呃，
[S01] 一个患有低血糖的司机开着一辆福特皮卡，直接撞穿了数据中心的墙壁，把整个空调冷却系统给撞烂了。
[S02] 哇哦，
[S02] 物理意义上的直接破坏，这个确实防不胜防。
[S01] 没错，这就是现实世界的宕机。
[S01] 欢迎来到本次深度探讨。
[S01] 呃，
[S01] 今天这一趟为你量身定制的知识之旅呢，我们要直面现代互联网背后极其混乱的现实。
[S02] 也就是平时那些看起来极其顺滑的云服务底层的真相。
[S01] 对的，
[S01] 今天我们要深挖的是经典著作《设计数据密集型应用》，也就是大家常说的 DDIAA的第九章，
[S01] 主题叫做分布式系统的麻烦。我们要去看看这个随时可能崩溃，充满谎言的疯狂世界。
[S02] 确实，
[S02] 了解这些绝对能彻底颠覆你对所谓系统可靠性的固有认知。
[S01] 好吧，
[S01] 让我们来拆解一下，那个我们在用单台电脑的时候，
[S01] 体验其实是非常确定的，对吧？
[S02] 对，非黑即白，
[S02] 要么好好运行，
[S02] 要么主板烧了直接死机。
[S01] 但我看到资料里说分布式系统完全是另一回事儿。我可以打个比方，
[S01] 呃，
[S01] 单台电脑就像是你自己开车自驾游，引擎坏了，车就停了，结果非常明确。
[S02] 嗯，非常精准的类比。
[S01] 但分布式系统呢，就像是你带着一个几千辆车组车的车队在跑，
[S01] 有的车迷路了，
[S01] 有的车半路爆胎了，甚至有的车还在开，但是车里的对讲机坏了。
[S02] 没错，谁也联系不上谁。
[S01] 对，整个车队其实还在前进，但处于一种极其混乱的非确定性状态中。这也就是资料里提到的部分失效，对吧？
[S02] 如果把它和更大的图景联系起来看，这种部分失效其实是物理世界的常态。你想啊一件事发生故障的概率，如果只有百万分之一。
[S01] 听起来非常小。
[S02] 对，但在世界中心里，
[S02] 当你有一万台机器，每天处理上亿次请调时，这个百万分之一每天都在发生。
[S01] 单台计算机那种指令完备执行的数学模型，其实是硬件工程师刻意给你营造的幻觉。
[S02] 就是为了掩盖物理世界的混乱。
[S02] 没错，在庞大的系统里，
[S02] 网线会被拔掉，甚至刚刚你说的皮卡车撞进机房。所以现代系统设计必须直面这种悲观的现实。
[S02] 在分布式系统里，偏执和怀疑绝对是有回报的。
[S01] 哇，所以怀疑一切就对了。
[S01] 那既然部分失效是常态，这些机器之间又是怎么沟通的？这就不得不提资料里的头号罪魁祸首了，那就是那个不可靠的网络。
[S02] 也就是异不分踪的网络，这里的麻烦可太大了。
[S01] 对，我看到里面有个非常经典的困境，我把它叫做薛定谔的请求。就是当你向另一台服务器发了一个请求，但是没收到响应的时候，你其实根本不知道对面发生了什么。
[S02] 因为你唯一能确定的只有你自己没有收到回复。
[S01] 对对对。
[S02] 这背后可能有三种截然不同的灾难。第一就是你的请求在半路上的某个路由器里直接丢了。
[S01] 第二，请求到了，但接收方的机器刚好在那一瞬间断电宕机了。
[S02] 嗯，这前两种还好，
[S02] 第三种是最折磨人的吧。
[S01] 是的，
[S01] 第三种就是接收方不仅收到了，还完美的处理了你的请求。比如说已经从你的账户里扣了钱，但是发回给你的那句处理成功的消息，在回来的路上丢了。
[S02] 天呐，尤其涉及到钱的时候，
[S02] 这就太可怕了。所以程序员唯一能做的就是设置一个超时时间，等个五秒没回复，就当它失带了。
[S01] 对，只能用超时来盲猜。
[S02] 但是等一下，我这里有个很大的疑问，要替大家问问，我们平时上网底层用的不都是TCP协议吗？教科书上不都写着TCP是可靠传输，内置了重传机制吗？为什么我们还要担心网络不可靠？
[S01] 这是一个非常普遍的误区，很多人简直把TCP当成了万能药。但这里有个极其残酷的现实，就是TCP掩盖不了应用层的失败。
[S02] 嗯，怎么说？
[S01] 就是说TCP确实在系统的核心层帮你保证了数据报送达。但假设对方机器的核心确实收到了数据，TCP也非常尽责的给你发回了一个确认收到的信号。
[S02] 嗯，这个听起来很靠谱啊。
[S01] 但是就在这个时候，
[S01] 对方机器上的应用程序还没来得及把数据从核心读出来，
[S01] 程序突然崩溃了，或者发生了内存溢出。
[S02] 哇，也就是说我的机器以为对方成功收到了，因为底层TCP说OK,但真正干活那个程序其实根本没看到这笔数据，
[S02] 它已经死了。没错，所以底层可靠不代表应用层可靠，更别提物理层面的破坏了。除了皮卡车，
[S02] 资料里还提到光纤会被牛踩断，被海狸咬断。
[S02] 哈哈。
[S01] 甚至还有鲨鱼咬断海底电缆的轶事。
[S02] 对，如果物理网线彻底断了，发生所谓的网络分区，TCP除了不断报错，根本无能为力。
[S01] 原来如此。嗯，
[S01] 那除了彻底断开网络，还有一个让人非常抓狂的特性叫无界延迟，就是根本不知道一个包在路上要走多长时间。
[S02] 排队延迟，这个是互联网的宿命。
[S01] 对，这里我想问，为什么不能像以前打老式电话那样，我拨通电话，这条线就被咱俩占了，
[S01] 延迟是固定的。现在的互联网为什么不用这种电路交换？
[S02] 因为太贵了。如果互联网用电路交换，你要传个文件，
[S02] 网络就得给你留一条固定贷款，哪怕你中途去倒了杯水，那几秒钟没传数据，别人也不能碰你的贷款。
[S01] 也就是极度的浪费。
[S02] 对，所以互联网采用了分组交换，大家把数据切成小块，在一个池子里动态抢占资源，
[S02] 这是为了应对互联网那种突发的流量。
[S01] 就是瞬间涌入海量数据的时候，
[S01] 交换机处理不过来，数据包就只能在内存里排队，
[S01] 这就产生了无界延迟。
[S02] 是的，如果队列满了，
[S02] 多出来的包就会被无情丢弃，然后触发重传，延迟就彻底不可控了。
[S01] 明白了，所以对你也就是我们的听众来说，意味着什么呢？
[S01] 其实这就是一笔经济账，
[S01] 我们忍受网络延迟的不可预测，是因为这种资源共享把成本压到了最低，让云服务变得非常便宜。
[S02] 没错，是成本和可预测性之间的权衡。
[S01] 好吧，呃，既然网络是个不可靠铺的骗子，那我们的系统在判断事情先后顺序的时候，能不能干脆绕开网络，
[S01] 呃，
[S01] 直接看机器上自己的手表，
[S01] 大家都有系统时间，对吧？
[S02] 呃，在分布式系统里，
[S02] 过度信任时间绝对会把你推向深渊。
[S01] 啊，时间不是绝对真理吗？
[S02] 并不是计算机里的时间主要分两种，日历时钟或单调时钟，平时应用里用的几点几分，那是日历时钟，它必须依赖NTP服务来同步。
[S01] 也就是通过网络去中心服务，
[S01] 问现在几点了，对吧？
[S02] 对，但我们刚刚才证明了网络是有延迟而且不可控的。所以NTP同步过来的时间本身就有误差。最要命的是，如果你的时服务器时间走得太快，NTP强制同步时，甚至会把时间往回调。
[S01] 呃，等一下，时间倒流，这在程序里绝对是灾难吧。
[S02] 绝对的灾难。比如说资料里提到的那个叫最后写入胜利的策略，就是LWW.
[S01] 嗯，这个策略怎么了？
[S02] 假设有两个节点同时修改一个数据，
[S02] 系统怎么决定听谁的？他看一眼时间戳，留下最新的那个。但如果其中一台机器的时钟慢了，
[S02] 因果关系就被颠倒了。你明明是后写的数据，被系统判定为旧数据，
[S02] 直接静默覆盖丢弃了。
[S01] 天呐，数据就这么凭空蒸发了，甚至连个报错都没有。
[S02] 是的，所以单调时钟相对好一点，它就像个秒表，只测量时间间隔，不会倒流，非常适合用来计算超时。
[S01] 嗯，像秒表一样就安全多了。但是既然NTP这么不靠谱，像谷歌这种巨头是怎么解决跨国数据中心时间对齐问题的？
[S02] 这里最令人着迷的是谷歌SPANER数据库的设计，他们搞了一个叫TRUTIME的API.
[S01] 听说底层用了原子钟和GPS.
[S02] 对，但最绝妙的不是硬件，
[S02] 而是它的思维方式。
[S02] Trutime绝对不会告诉你现在是精准的几分几秒，它会给你返还一个置信区间。
[S01] 呃，置信区间意思是它会说我不知道现在几点，但我确信现在的时间在一个最早时间和最晚时间之间。
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 当SPANER要保证两个操作的顺序时，
[S02] 它就干脆等待，强行等待那个不确定性的时间窗口过去，确保前一个操作的最晚时间，绝对早于后一个操作的最早时间。
[S01] 哇，通过物理上的等待来消灭时间交叠，这个脑回路太惊艳了。
[S02] 是的，承认不确定性，然后消化它。
[S01] 不过时间的诡异之处还不止于此哦。
[S01] 资料里提到一个让人后背发凉的现象，叫做进程暂停。
[S02] 真正有趣的地方来了。
[S01] 嗯，比如Java的拉齐回收，也就是GC暂停。
[S02] 对，
[S02] 让我来打个比方，这就好比你正在听我们这场深度探讨，突然我作为主持人睡着了。这十五秒钟我失去意识，一动不动，等我醒过来，我以为自己还是主持人，准备接着刚才的话茬说。
[S01] 但现实是，这十五秒里，
[S01] 系统早就把你踢出去了。
[S02] 没错，大家以为我掉线了，选了新的主持人，可我自己完全没意识到时间已经流失了，这就引出了一个大问题。
[S01] 也就是所谓的僵尸怒点。是的，如果这种沉睡没意识到自己失去权力的僵尸节点，醒来后继续向系统写入数据，
[S01] 岂不是会造成灾难？整个系统到底该怎么确定什么是真相？
[S02] 这是个极其深刻的问题。
[S02] 在分布式系统里，没有绝对的真理，真相是由多数派投票决定的。
[S01] 嗯，也就是QUARMS多数派原则。
[S02] 对，只要集群里多数机器认为你死了，哪怕你觉得你自己活蹦乱跳，你也必须服从大局，你就是死了。
[S01] 少数服从多数，
[S01] 那有没有可能有些节点不仅是死了，
[S01] 它还故意撒谎呢？
[S02] 呃，这就属于拜占庭故障了。比如航天器受辐射，数据翻转或者加密货币里有恶意节点。
[S01] 哦，但在我们讨论的企业级数据中心里，通常不考虑这种恶意撒谎吧。
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 企业内网里，我们假设节点是诚实但容易出错的。所以回到你的那个僵尸节点问题，
[S02] 系统需要一种物理机制来拦住它。
[S01] 对，
[S01] 资料里提到了终极武器叫隔离令牌。
[S02] 这个机制极其聪明，每次系统通过多数派选出新领导时，都会给他颁发一个单调递增的数字令牌。
[S01] 也就是比如旧领导是三十三号，新领导就是三十四号。
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 当那个沉睡的三十三号僵尸醒来，拿着旧令牌去存储服务器写数据时，
[S01] 存储服务器像个铁面无私的保安，对吧？
[S02] 对，
[S02] 保安会说，抱歉，
[S02] 我已经见过拿着三十四号令牌的新领导了，你的三十三号直接作废，你被拒之门外了，
[S02] 这就叫隔离。
[S01] 哇，所以大家千万不要在分布式系统中盲目相信所谓的唯一锁或者租约。因为拿着锁的节点可能早就变成僵尸了，
[S01] 必须得有服务端的验证机制。
[S02] 是的，这绝对是一种极其严谨的系统思维。
[S01] 听起来分布式系统就像是建在流沙上的城堡，
[S01] 网络随时断，时间往回走，僵尸节点到处跑。
[S01] 那么这一切到底意味着什么？工程师是怎么保证像奈飞、阿玛宗像这样的巨头不肯被的？
[S02] 他们靠的是构建系统模型，比如最贴近现实的叫做部分同步模型。
[S01] 也就是假设系统大部分时间正常，但随时会陷入无法预测的混乱。
[S02] 没错，最难搞的其实不是直接坑帮，而是波形节点，也就是半死不活的节点拖慢整个系统。为了应对这些，工程师用安全性，也就是坏事永远不发生，以及活性，也就是好事最终会发生来定义正确性。
[S01] 可是理论再完美，代码也不能明BUG啊，
[S01] 我们总不能把代码写完，就直接扔进混乱的真实环境里去鞭斥吧。
[S02] 呃，其实就是要扔进去鞭斥，这就是现代测试方法的作用。比如NETFLIX非常有名的CHAOSMONKEY混动猴子。
[S01] 哇，这个我知道，就是在生产环境的大白天写个脚本，随机拔网线，强制关机器来看看系统反应。
[S02] 对，就是这么硬核。还有一种更神奇的叫确定性模拟测试，比如FOUNDATIONDB用的。他们把所有非确定性的网络延迟时钟全放在一个巨大的模拟器里控制起来。
[S01] 也就是把一切随机因素变成可控的。这样一旦发现BUG就能百分之百复现。
[S02] 没错，在分布式世界里，这简直就是拥有了掌控时间的超能力。
[S01] 真是太疯狂的这趟旅程，从皮卡车撞墙到撒谎的网络，再到时间倒流和僵尸节点。总结一下，
[S01] 我们绝对不能指望完美的硬件或网络，所有的可靠性都必须在不确定的流沙中，通过软件容错、隔离令牌和多数派投票来顽强构建。
[S02] 是的，这就是在混乱中构建确定性的终极艺术。
[S01] 那么在今天结束之前，我想给你抛出一个发人省省的问题。
[S01] 在分布式系统里，
[S01] 我们发现没有绝对的全局时钟，也没有完美的单点真相。整个系统靠概率共识和容忍实施顽强存活。
[S02] 嗯。
[S01] 那如果你把这种思维用到人类社会呢，我们的人类组织、公司架构，甚至未来的AI协作网络，是不是也不应该追求僵化完美的中心化控制？
[S01] 我们是不是更应该拥抱非确定性，
[S01] 设计出像分布式系统那样，哪怕一部分崩溃，也能自我修复并继续前进的部分同步组织形态呢？
[S02] 非常值得深思的角度。
[S01] 感谢你收听本次深度探讨，希望你在日常中也能发现这些隐藏在复杂表象下的架构之美，下次见。